SLAP SLAP SLAP SLAP SLAP SLAP
*explosion*
*poof transition*
But what annoys you, besides me?
I'm annoyed by a great many things: the wind
Markiplier- oh fuck you! Fuck you man!
*poof transition*
Hi
Ehh!
Eh!
HA!
*Horrible french accent* Hello sir, may I take your order?
Excuse me, sir, may I take your order please?
Pretty, pretty please
May I take your order?
Huh?
Bon, oui
(Good, yes)
Oh merci
(Thank you)
Oh tres bien
(Very good)
Huh!
Sacré bleu!
(Damn it!)
*poof transition*
*laughs*
Why are you s- why is he thrusting?
Why is he thrusting into the ground? Dude!
Stop!
Oh wow
Heh!
Yea, this is good for lumbar support
Alright. Oh, I can walk with my human legs!
Oh, I can try to not spill my human coffee!
Let me just thrust upwards
*poof transition*
Eh oh!
eh eh
oh eh eh!
*french accent* Hello sir, can I show you to your tableh?
Ahh!
Aw, sit
Eh
Oh!
Well, ain't this a predicamo
*poof transition*
Give me fuel, give me fire, give me that which I desire
OIL!
*poof transition*
Heh
HEH!
*Panting with the occasional pained scream*
I'm so cold
But I'm burning on the inside out!
*low, shuddery scream*
What are you laughing at?!
*poof transition*
Well let's go, because I hear a pot of-
*sounds of a person chewing presumably carrots*
Uh, oh God
Ah, stop it
Oh, its so gross! Stop that!
*poof transition*
Oh, that is Rob. Hi Rob. How you doin', Rob?
Well.. We're going to have ourselves a good old time when 🎵we're fighting together🎵
🎵Together forever! You can't run away from your fate Robbie Rob!🎵
Did I kill him? No. Yes?
Did I? Yea!
*poof transition*
*Here we see the rare Markiplier in his natural habitat*
*Reading from game* "Do you have a happy place?" *chuckles* and can I see it?
"I was once give the name.. 'Joyless Husk'"???
*poof transition*
I'm sure *french laugh*
Lotion keeps you skin supple and stretchy..?
*poof transition*
*Mark tryin' to catch a pen with his mouth*
(Are you ok Mark?)
Shut up! This isn't about you!
*Catching pens continues*
It was inside me!
*Mark successfully catch the pen*
*slow-mode vid*
*Markiplier.exe has stopped working*
(Oh my God, what's happening?)
*poof transition*
Ahh!
Oh! WOAH! Woah, woah
The grundle on that jar of mayo is not okay!
"But I forgot my apartment was an armpit, so I was screwed!" What?
Oh God
Oh God! Oh my God *giggles*
Oh, is that a potato!?
Oh- someone call Jacksepticeye, this is getting hot in here!
"You're not into my banana suits? How 'bout this?" Well, you should know
It's m- WOAH!
*poof transition*
Psh, I ain't scared. Let me show you!
Here we go! Any day now! Let's go!
Hammertime, Mo- Twerk! Okay, I'm good with that
Oh yea, oh yea! Oh Markie likes!
*poof transition*
Mark/Wade: Were going to jail!
Gar: Were going to jail? *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Gar: For what crime?
Mark: You disrespected a well known Youtuber li- that's, that's not allowed, come on now
Wade: Bye Monkey! *maniacal laughs*
Mark: Bye Monkey, Bye! *laughs*
Mark: Ok bye!
Patrick: Bye Wade!
Mark: Bye Wade!
Wade: Bye Monkey! *maniacal laughs*
*poof transition*
Can't get me! Can't get me! Can't get me!
Ca- Ah, they got me
[game] *demonic laugh*
Don't laugh at me
You wouldn't laugh at a guy with glasses would you? AH!
*poof transition*
Ah! Oh! Woah *giggles*
Aha!
*laughs*
HA HA!
HA HA? HA!
*giggles*
Hi Boobs Mackenzie!
HABUF-- Ooohhhh
*giggles* Hohhohohohohoho! (Santaplier, is that you?!)
Hi Boobsie
Boobsie? Boobsie?! Boobsie?
*Mark's demonic senpai screech*
You're about to love me!
*Mark's demonic senpai screech x2*
You don't know it yet!
*Mark's demonic senpai screech x3*
You're gonna love me! *weirdly mumbled*
*Mark's demonic senpai screech x4* (Should I call an ambulance Mark?)
If there's no one left not to love
*Mark's demonic senpai screech x5* (Ok! I think this is serious)
Who would you love
*Mark's demonic senpai screech x6* (I think Mark's gonna die. NO!)
but me?
*A very long demonic senpai screech*
Hi.
Thanks for watching! All of the videos in this compilation are available in the description, so check them out!
And if you'd like to see more in the future, please leave a like to let me know
If you enjoyed this video and you'd like to see more on a daily basis, please subscribe today
Or, if you're already subscribed, share this video with a friend
Thanks again for watching. And I'll see YOU in the next video
BUH-BYE!! :)